well I hope that the brexit secretary is
going to take the malt house compromise
proposals for replacing the backstop to
Brussels as government policy I think
part of the problem last night was a
loss of faith that the government is
really committed to this compromise now
let's just you know reiterate what this
compromise represents it is remain us
like Damien green and Nicky Morgan and
levers like Jacob Riis MOG and Ian
Duncan Smith agreeing on how to resolve
the border issue in Northern Ireland in
a way that doesn't lock us permanently
into a customs union that doesn't
separate Northern Ireland and treat
Northern Ireland differently from the
United Kingdom and which provides an
opportunity for the United Kingdom to
move forward unilaterally on its own
without the permission of the European
Union at some date in the future that's
very important that's what's
fundamentally them it is the most
fundamental problem in the withdrawal
agreement and the government needs to
adopt that as policy and sell it to
Brussels as hard as it can if the
government doesn't accept it as policy
and there is no support for this
Malthouse compromised immune AU or it's
all concern that what may eventually
happen is that you'll see a softer form
of breakfast that's affirmed what Jeremy
Corbyn has been calling for a customs
union and a single market because MPs
will say that they have no option but to
support that proposal well of course
that wouldn't be brexit if you have if
you're inside the customs union and
you're accepting the single market rules
sale in the single market as the Labour
front bench has already made clear that
means we would have free movement of
people and if both main parties went
along with that both main parties would
be breaching the commitments we jointly
made in our manifestos to leave the
European Union and it would be not
deliberate well if I may just finish and
it would not be delivering what fifty
two percent of the country vote voted
for which was to leave the European
Union I mean I can't see why I can't
understand why people can't get their
brains around this except of course 75
percent of MPs didn't vote leave their
remainders and some of them can't get
over it yeah but people can't get their
brains rounded because they're concerned
of the long term implications if we do
leave on WTO rules well
part of the compromise are the terms
upon which we would leave on WTA rules
that which would be to invoke article 24
of GATT to ensure that there aren't
tariffs now nobody in the EU exporting
to the UK wants tariffs nor the UK
exporters to the EU want tariffs that
there should be agreement that we could
go into a basic free trade agreement for
goods as part of the implementation
period under the withdrawal agreement
pending the negotiation of a free trade
agreement at some future date the only
obstacle that is standing in the way of
this at the moment is the equivocation
of the United Kingdom government and
that's why I'm afraid a lot of my
colleagues were threatening to vote
against the government last night we
persuaded them to compromise and we all
voted - we all decided to abstain but
it's the government's good faith in this
exercise that is required and then let's
face it the European Union is and and
you've just heard the Irish Prime
Minister mr. a mr. Baraka they're
beginning to get very concerned about
the prospect of us leaving without any
agreement at all and nobody wants that
yeah they are become very concerned but
they're also saying under no
circumstances and withdrawal agreement
will be reopened well they would say
that wouldn't they and they're also
saying they're waiting to see concrete
proposals as president tusk said earlier
this week waiting to see concrete
proposals for an alternative backstop
from the United Kingdom government
that's what's lacking at the moment and
that's what I hope Steve Barclay will be
taking to Brussels next week what do you
make of the Business Minister Richard
Harrington's comments that what
politicians MPs like yourself in the ERG
your actions are treacherous what do you
make of that well I think people are
getting very het up and emotional I
think some things are better left unsaid
and if he's so unhappy with the conduct
of government policy and keeps
threatening to resign perhaps he should
resign as the accusation and that your
reporter within a party now know the
people who have been holding the
government to ransom are the tiny
minority of unreconciled remainders who
are trying to stop brexit
people campaigning for a second
referendum there people who say things
like that leaving the European Union is
an act of self-harm or self-mutilation
and these are equally extreme comments
and I think they don't accept that the
United Kingdom voted to leave the house
but we wouldn't be in this political
crisis if the House of Commons had
accepted that we were going to leave
accepted the referendum result most MPs
have voted for article 50 and we passed
the withdrawal act and then they seem to
be backtracking you know that we've just
got to get through this and you know
this is not this is a political crisis
it's not an economic crisis our economy
is actually growing faster than most of
the European Union faster the incredibly
slow rates well nobody's enjoying the
present uncertainty and we can end the
uncertainty indeed we could end the
uncertainty very much more quickly by
leaving without a withdrawal agreement
but we're prepared to compromise and
vote for the withdrawal agreement if we
sort out this dreadful backstop that's
that's how far the levers are prepared
to compromise and let's see some
compromise from the other side could you
not intend the uncertainty by supporting
the Prime Minister's deal well it would
it would create an an ever ending
uncertainty because we would be entering
an agreement which we might never be
able to get out of at least you can
leave the European Union as the
withdrawal agreement is currently
constituted the as the Attorney General
explained to the House of Commons there
is no means of the United Kingdom
deciding to leave that arrangement
unilaterally we would require the
permission of the European Union now no
responsible House of Commons could vote
for such an agreement which is why it
lost by 230 votes and the message should
be perfectly clear that that agreement
as it is is not going to be approved by
the House of Commons
burnin jenkin thanks Peter very much